you know what the king you'll be queen
for a time this alleged witch woman made
certain prophecies and that were
enigmatic at first that doesn't make
sense gold will be their crowns called
shrouds certainly this is a society
where people believe in in magic they
believe in sorcery and with good reason
because it exists this is a world where
you have dragons and you have had giants
and children of the forest and and other
things that are not part of the actual
medieval world and yet have been part of
the world of Westeros for thousands of
years you don't know I know you're a
witch and you can see the future
I think seriously probably worried about
that for time and then forgot about it
but now certain aspects of Maggie's
prophecies come true and that alarm sir
because it creates the possibility that
that will come true she doesn't want to
believe this but you know it's nagging
her it's at the back of the mind that's
making her even more protective of
herself and her children and and even
more suspicious of anyone she thinks
might want to do them harm the faith of
the seven is having what you could only
call a Reformation movement and has
become very corrupt by the time my Game
of Thrones opens you know the High
Septon who is the equivalent of the Pope
is fat
sensual man and when that High Septon is
removed then now it's time to elect a
new pope that common people are called
sparrows one of them who is handpicked
by sirs it becomes High Septon and of
course he gets called the high Sparrow
well I tell them no one's special and
they think I'm special for telling
himself
perhaps the right Cersei and the Lords
of King's Landing find they have a
person who wants to serve the poor who's
cleaning out the corruption in order to
get what she wants she allows him to
revive the faith militant laws teach
people to obey the sword not the gods
perhaps the gods need a sword of their
own hundreds of years before the
Targaryen arrival the faith had military
arms with which to enforced it will
essentially the fighting monks by
allowing the faith to take up arms again
you're seeing the recreation of these
fighting forces of young men pledged to
the personal defense of the faith in the
High Septon suddenly there's a whole new
player in the game all sinners are equal
before the gods
who lay with a man outside the bonds of
marriage I confess you have taken the
first step in the path back to
righteousness after your atonement there
are symbolic aspects to the walk of
atonement or the walk of shame you're
naked you have nothing to hide or
concealment has been denied you your
hair has all been shaved off you are
completely vulnerable
you're just have nothing more to hide I
bear all before God and that's the
spiritual justification for this kind of
thing but there's also a very deliberate
political aspect of it a sinner comes
before you Cersei of House Lannister
people didn't see the Kings and their
Lords very often except when they passed
by and they're incredibly lavish outfits
the splendor of them the way they'd
littered helped them rule because it
over ORD the populace when you take all
of that away from a queen like Cersei
who after then has only been seen by her
subjects as this incredibly beautiful
woman attended by maids and protected by
knights it's a way to stripper of all of
the power that attends to her majesty
shame
Shane Shane Shane Shane
Cersei is not beloved in the streets of
King's Landing this is a woman who you
dare not contradict or she could have
your tongue torn out and now people were
calling her filthy names and and
accusations and they're do free to do so
it changes the entire public perception
of them and that is obviously part of
the intent indeed she goes out defiant
but she's broken and damaged by the end
of it